ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL BACK REAL
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLUE.
BURNER BONTA BURKE CALDERON-
RIO CERVANTES CHAU JUNE CHIU
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GONZALEZ
GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY
LEE LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN- SUCI THIS AREA WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK WORKS.
RAMOS RARE THREE OF US ROBERT
READ ROGER. RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. SMITH STONE TEEN
CALAVERAS VEHICLE BY A VOEPEL
WELL. WARD WICKS WORD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. OH MY GOD.
WE ASK YOU OF YOUR MERCY BUT
YOU BLESSED US WITH QUALITIES.
NOT ALLOW US TO REMAIN GROUNDED
IN HUMILITY AND EMPATHY. BLESS
US WITH HEARTS AND MINDS THAT
ALLOW US TO NO MATTER HOW FAR
YOU GO IN LIFE LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE THROUGH THE NOISE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE ARE EXPERIENCING
AS HUMAN BEINGS. GIVE US THE
COURAGE TO FILTER OUT SUCH
NOISE. BUT IN RETURN ALLOWS US
TO BE ROLE MODELS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS I MEAN. THANK YOU
BOB YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN REPUBLICAN LEADER
MARIE WALDRON. WHO WILL LEAD US
IN THE PLEDGE MISTER WALTER.
PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE SALUTE OUR
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. OR. YEAH. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S SOME RESEARCHERS
ARE WINS SAID TWENTY TWO ONE
YOU SEE ME MINUTES AM AUDIBLE
BECAUSE GARCIA SIMPLY FIFTY
DISTRICT TO CLERK SIX DE FOR
GOING READ MAYES RARE MOVE. MS
WALDRON SAID. THAT THE RE OF
THE PRE DAY'S BE TO WITH.
PRESIDENT OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
BOWING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES. WILL BE TO
PROCEDURAL. MOTIONS. MEMBERS.
MS RAY S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO ALONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ELECT A KILO WEBER TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
AT HER DESK ON THE FLOOR AND AT
THE ROSTRUM FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE OATH OF
OFFICE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO ORDER AB
FIVE TO SEVEN WORD TO THE FIRST
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR THE BILL
WAS A RONI ASTLEY REPORTED OUT
AS DO PASS INSTEAD OF DO PASSED
TO CONSENT CALENDAR. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PERCENT ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB SIX NINE FOUR BY
THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE AND AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT LOW FROM THE
REVENUE ATTACKS TAXATION
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEE STUDENT NOTICED THE
BILLS PENDING REFERRAL FROM
OTHER COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW
NATURAL RESOURCE COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE EIGHTY FIVE TWO FIVE TWO
FOR THEIR HEARING ON APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTH PENDING REFERRAL
FROM UTILITIES AND ENERGY. TO
ALLOW PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
AB TEN SEVENTY SIX KILEY FOR
THEIR HEARING. ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND. PENDING REFERRAL FROM
TRANSPORTATION. TO ALLOW
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
APRIL TWENTY SEVEN HEARING. AB
TWO FIVE SEVEN GONZALEZ AND AB
TEN THIRTY THREE BAIER KM.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT. AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN GABRIEL IN AB TWELVE
ELEVEN RESEARCHING PENDING
REFERRAL FROM PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN CERVANTES
PENDING REFERRAL FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY THREE LOW FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IN ORDER THE
BILL TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST
IS GRANTED AND THE CLERK WILL
NOT. AND FINALLY AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE REMOVE
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE ARAMBULA. AND ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE
FOURTEEN IRWIN. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE.
MEMBERS. THE NEW YORK
ELECTED MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
JOINS US TODAY. MEMBERS AND
GUESTS A SPECIAL ELECTION WAS
HELD TO FILL THE VACANCY IN THE
SEVEN NINE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
DR KILO WEBER IS THE ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES OF THAT
DISTRICT. I ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIKE WEBER AND HER FAMILY TO
COME FORWARD TO THE RESTAURANT.
OKAY.
THERE IS A CERTIFICATE OF
ELECTION FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AT THE ASSEMBLY DESK THE
CLERK WILL READ YOU
CERTIFICATES OF ELECTION I
SURELY IN WEBER PHD SECRETARY
OF STATE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HEREBY CERTIFY THAT
ACCORDING TO INFORMATION
CONCERNING THE STATEMENT OF THE
RESULTS OF THE SPECIAL PRIMARY
ELECTION HELD ON APRIL SIX
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ON FILE IN MY
OFFICE AKELA WEBER WAS ELECTED
TO THE OFFICE OF STATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DISTRICTS SEVENTY NINE
IN WITNESS ROCA HEREUNTO SETT
MY HAND IN A FIX THE GREAT SEAL
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT
SACRAMENTO ON THIS DATE APRIL
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
SURELY AND WEBER PHD SECRETARY
OF STATE WITHOUT OBJECTION
CERTIFICATE OF ELECTION AS
ORDERED PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELECTED CABLE
WEBER WILL NOW TAKE THE OATH OF
OFFICE AS SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY DOES MY PRIVILEGE TO
INTRODUCE A SPECIAL GUESTS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE OATH.
SHE IS A FORMER MEMBER OF THIS
HOUSE WAS HELD IN GREAT ESTEEM.
SHE IS ALSO THE MOTHER OF DR
KEY LEVER. TODAY HISTORIC IT IS
THE FIRST TIME A MOTHER WHO IS
A STATE WIDE OFFICER HAS SWORN
IN A DAUGHTER FOR STATE.
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. WE ARE VERY
VERY PROUD TO WELCOME BACK.
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF STATE
THE HONORABLE DOCTOR SURELY
NASH WEBER. SECRETARY WHAT.
I
COULD NOT. LET OF DOING THIS.
I'VE SAID CONSISTENTLY TO MY
DAUGHTER AS WE TAKE THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO BE CAREFULLY TO READ
WHAT IT SAYS. BECAUSE IN MANY
CASES WE DON'T REALLY REALIZE
WHAT WE'RE SAYING. BUT WHAT WE
ARE SAYING VERY CLEARLY. IS
THAT OFTENTIMES YOU ARE THE
FIRST. THE LAST AND SOMETIMES
THE ONLY. DEFENSE OF DEMOCRACY
AGAINST TYRANNY. AND WE TAKE
THAT OLD VERY SERIOUSLY INTO
JOINING THE SEVENTY NINE OF YOU
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DEMOCRACY REMAINS A DEMOCRACY
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND SO
I'M HONORED TODAY AS A ELECTED
OFFICIAL STATEWIDE OFFICER BUT
ALSO AS A MOM. TO BE ABLE TO
SWEAR IN DR KILO WEBER AND HER
FAMILY THAT'S WITH THIS MY
GRANDSONS INTERNET. APPEALABLE
YOU RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND. I
STATE YOUR NAME I THINK HE WILL
EVER DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR TO
FALLON WHERE THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES AGAINST
ALL. FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC AND THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND I'LL-
ALLEGIANCE AND ALLEGIANCE TO
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CONSTITUTION
EVERYTHING ELSE. THAT I TAKE
THIS OBLIGATION FREELY.
APPLICATION REALLY WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION OR PURPOSE
OF EVASION OR PURPOSE
EVERYTHING AND THAT I WILL WELL.
AND FAITHFULLY AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE- EFFECTIVITY UPON
WHICH I'M ABOUT TO ENTER UPON
WHICH AM ABOUT. CONGRATULATIONS
THANK.
DR WEBER ASSIGNING HER
UP OF OFFICE.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT OUR
NEWEST CALLING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
FOR THE PURPOSE OF INTERACTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE MY
GUEST. I'M HERE ON THE FLOOR
WITH ME AS YOU ALL KNOW VERY
WELL AS MY MOTHER SECRETARY OF
STATE DR SHIRLEY WEBER. I'M
ALSO JOINED AT MY DESK BY MY
TWO BOYS WHO ARE MY HARD DRIVE-
YOU DEAR. ANGELO WHO IS SEVEN
AND A HALF. EVEN IN THE BACK-
DENNIS. IN THE GALA AND I HE'LL
WEBER IS RIGHT THERE. I ALSO
HAVE UNTIL ON MAXI CHARLENE
HENDERSON WHO AE THE. MY THREE
HUNDRED IS A P. MY FRIEND JUST
WHO FLEW IN FROM DIEGO AND.
THERE ARE SEVERAL ENCOURAGE
FORMER STAFF MEMBERS OF THE
REALLY WHERE THEY'RE ALL
PRESENT THE GALLERY BUT WHO ARE
LIKE THE- TO US. I AM EXCITED
BE HERE I WOULD LIKE FIRST
THANK THE RESIDENTS OF THE
SEVENTY NINTH ASSEMBLY. WHO WHO
SPOKE VERY LOUDLY AS TO WHO
THEY WANTED TO REPRESENT THEM I
AM VERY PROUD HONORED THAT THEY
HAVE JUST BESTOWED THEIR TRUST
IN ME- AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM AND FOR THEM
EVERY DAY. SECOND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY MANY OF YOU HELPED MY
COUNT MY CAMPAIGN OUT
TREMENDOUSLY AND I THANK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR THAT. I
KNOW THAT HERE THIS IS WHERE WE
MAKE SIGNIFICANT LAWS THAT HAVE
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON EVERY
SINGLE RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T TAKE THAT LIGHTLY. I
KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO. AND I AM
VERY HONORED THAT I AM HERE TO
HELP DO IT. AND SO WITH THAT.
I'M READY TO GET TO WORK. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU SIMILAR
MEMBER WHATEVER THIS ENDS THE
SWEARING IN SOME CEREMONY WE
WILL NOW MOVES TO REGULAR
BUSINESS.
MEMBERS MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. HELLO.
MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY RELIVING FORTY WITH A
MEMBERS FIVE EIGHTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS NINE OF THE MEMBERS A
NINETY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS ALL
FIFTY FIVE OF THE MEMBERS
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WITH A
MEMBERS FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE
WITH A MEMBER SAY TWENTY SIX
MINUTES NINETY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS FOR FOURTEEN FOUR SIXTY
FOUR SIX OH TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
WILL SEVENTY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO WITH A
MEMBERS FORTINO ONE OF THE
MEMBERS NOT ALL THREE WITH A
MEMBER SINCE TWENTY ONE WITH A
MEMBERS AND A CYNICAL FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS.
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. WILLING TO
RECONSIDERATION. THIS IS FILE
ITEM. NINETEEN KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER STONE AND OTHERS
AN ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES.
DOES ANY MEMBER OBJECT TO MR
STONE BEING GRANTED UNANIMOUS.
RECONSIDERATION. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE. THE CLERK WILL
AGAIN READ. RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AND OTHERS
AN ACT RELATING TO RENOUNCE. MR
STONE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THE COURTESY OF RECONSIDERATION
THIS IS AGAIN AB FIVE OH THREE
ENDING AND THE CYCLES OF
PROBATION FOR OUR YOUTH AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR STILL. SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. GLOBAL
ROLE ALL MEMBERS. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
ALL MEMBERS ARE RESERVE A.
MR
STONE LOSE THE CALL. MOVIE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
FILE ITEMS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM TWENTY
TWO AB TWO SEVEN FIVE BY MR
MEDINA CORCORAN. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO SEVENTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER MEDINA AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE EMPLOYEES.
ISSUE MEDINA EMAIL THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT A. B. TWO SEVENTY FIVE.
AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
REDUCE THE MAXIMUM PROBATIONARY
PERIOD FOR ALL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
WORKING IN A NON MERIT DISTRICT
FROM ONE YEAR TO SIX MONTHS. OR
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY DAYS OF
PAID SERVICE WHICHEVER IS
LONGER. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
MEMBERS WORKING IN THE NON
MERIT DISTRICTS NEED PARITY
WITH THOSE OF THEIR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MERIT DISTRICT
COUNTERPARTS. IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
HAVE A PROBATIONARY PERIOD
MAXIMUM OF ONE YEAR. WHAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN MERRITT
DISTRICTS ONLY HAVE A
PROBATIONARY PERIOD MAXIMUM OF
SIX MONTHS. TWO YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE. THAT
REDUCED THE PROBATIONARY PERIOD
OF K. TWELVE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS FROM ONE YEAR TO SIX
MONTHS. IN ALIGNMENT WITH K.
TWELVE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
WORKING IN MERRITT DISTRICTS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS WERE INADVERTENTLY
LEFT OUT. AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE
WILL SIMPLY CORRECT THIS
OVERSIGHT AND PROVIDE PARITY TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN NON MERIT
DISTRICTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLARK LOVE
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS BETTER DESERVE A. THE.
MEMBERS THAT ARE PRESENT IN A
READY TO GO GREAT- CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS. TWENTY
THREE. THROUGH TWENTY FIVE PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. A. B. FOUR THIRTY
NINE FIVE MISS AMERICA HAND
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAO QUE HAN AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO CERTIFICATES OF
DEATH THIS PARQUET. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS JAY I
RIGHTS PERCENT EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE A SIMPLE YET
MEANINGFUL ADDITION OF A SINGLE
WORD IN THE CODE ADDING IN NON
BINARY GENDER OPTION ON DEATH
CERTIFICATES LANGUAGE MATTERS
NON BINARY YOUTH WHO REPORTED
THEIR PRONOUNS WERE NOT
RESPECTED BY THOSE IN THEIR
LIVES WERE TWICE AS LIKELY TO
ATTEMPT SUICIDE IS THOSE WHO
CHRIS CORRECT PRONOUNS WERE
USED. THE RIGHTS OF TRANS AND
NON BINARY PEOPLE ARE BEING
THREATENED WITH BANDS ON VITAL
HEALTHCARE AND SPORTS
PARTICIPATION IN MANY STATES
THIS CONSTANT LEGAL AND SOCIAL
RASCHER IS A SOURCE OF PAIN AND
A VIOLATION OF BASIC RIGHTS FOR
TRANS AND NON BINARY PEOPLE I
AM PROUD TO BE PART OF THIS
LEGISLATURE IT IS MADE
CALIFORNIA A LEADER IN
PROTECTING LGBTQ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR RIGHT TO
LIVE AS THEIR FULL SELVES. THIS
BILL BUILT ON OUR STREETS
PREVIOUS CRITICAL WORK ALLOWING
NON VERY INNER OPTIONS ON LEGAL
DOCUMENTS SUCH AS DRIVER'S
LICENSE BY ADDING THE NON
BINARY IS AN OPTION FOR A DONE
FOR ADDING IT TO DEATH
CERTIFICATES AS WELL WHEN NON
BINARY PEOPLE PASS AWAY IT IS
ONLY JUST TO HAVE THEIR FULL
IDENTITY REFLECTED IN DEATH AS
IT WAS IN LIFE. INCORRECTLY
ASSIGNING THEIR GENDER IS
DISRESPECTFUL TO THEIR MEMORIES
THE BILL BRINGS CRITICS CALL
IDENTIFYING DOCUMENTS IN LINE
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL'S TRUE
IDENTITY PREVENTING PAINFUL
LEGAL DISCREPANCIES. WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
IS CARE SEEING. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CARCLUB THE
ROLE. THE DESIRED ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE DEVELOPED.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY THREE. NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
TWENTY SEVEN AND TWENTY EIGHT
PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE BY SOME MEMBER
BIGELOW AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS THIS
YOUR BIGELOW. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVEN NINE WILL ADD DEL
NORTE. MONO MADERA AND SAN
MATEO COUNTIES TO THE LIST OF
COUNTIES NOTED IN SECTION EIGHT
THREE OH POINT ONE C. OF THE
PENAL CODE ALLOWING DEPUTY
SHERIFF TO PERFORM THE DUTIES
OF A PEACE OFFICER RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BIGELOW. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLICK LIBERAL MEMBER.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF ALL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS TO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS THIRTY. THROUGH
THIRTY FIVE PASS RETAIN. FIVE
THIRTY SIX IS AB FOUR FIFTY
THREE. ACCORDING SOME PEOPLE
FOR FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
ACTIVATING THE CIVIL LAW. IS
GARCIA. AT THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY WOULD AMEND THE CIVIL
CODE LAW UNDER SEXUAL BATTERY
TO INCLUDE NONCONSENSUAL CONDOM
REMOVING ALSO KNOWN I FELT.
FELT IN IS THE NAME FOR AN
AGENT THINKING PRACTICE I IT IS
THE NONCONSENSUAL INTENTION
REMOVAL OR TAMPERING WITH
CONDOMS DURING SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE AND HAS BEEN ON THE
RISE FOR YEARS MOST RECENTLY
THE HBO DRAMA AND MAY DESTROY
YOU HE TELLS THE COMPELLING
DEPICTION OF THE HORRORS AND
TRAUMA SEXUAL ABUSE INCLUDING
STEALTHY. AB FORTY THREE WOULD
ENSURE VICTIMS CAN SEEK DAMAGES
IN ADDITION IT GIVES A- CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT THIS IS NOT ONLY
IMMORAL BUT ILLEGAL WHICH IS
KEY AND PREVENTED EDUCATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS GARCIA
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CABALLERO. WHAT IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS BETTER
DESERVE A.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN
PASS TEMPORARILY. A FILE ITEM
THIRTY FILE ITEMS. THIRTY NINE.
THROUGH FORTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN A BRIDGES TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN A. B. TWO SEVEN ONE
BY MR RIVAS CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS MYSTERY THIS
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SOME OF THE TWO SEVEN
ONE ONE AUTHORIZES SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT- VALLEY
WATER YOU THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT SYSTEM IN SELECTING
A CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTOR FOR A
MAJOR SEISMIC RETRO. FIT
PROJECT OF ANDERSON DOWN THE
COUNTY SANTA CLAUS LARGEST AND
MOST CRITICAL LOCAL WATER
STORAGE FACILITY THE COMPLETION
OF THIS PROJECT IS IMPERATIVE
AS A SAFETY RISK AT THIS DAM IS
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH. AND WOULD
NOT WITHSTAND A LARGE
EARTHQUAKE ON THE NEARBY
CALAVERAS OR COYOTE CREEK FAULT
LINES THIS LEGISLATION WILL
OFFER THE SAFEST BEST OVERALL
VALUE THE REMOVAL. FOR THE FOR
THE REMOVAL AN EXPERT
REPLACEMENT OF THIS CRITICAL
WATER STORAGE PROJECT ALSO SURE
THEY SKILLED TRADE WORKFORCE
WILL BE EMPLOYED FOR THIS
PROJECT RESPECT LAST WHEN I
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IN YOU MISTER OF US. C.
NOTIFICATION OF A. CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROLE. IT IS OUR TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
SARAJEVO. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS
AT ABOUT. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ARE ALL TIED UP I SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO. DAB MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FORTY EIGHT AND
FORTY NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY AB FIVE ONE FIVE CARBERY.
SUMITRO FIVE FIVE FIFTEEN BY
SOME CHEN AN ACT RELATING TO
TRESPASS DR CHEN EMAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
HERE PERCENT AB FIVE ONE FIVE A
BILL THAT WOULD CLARIFY
TRESPASSING PROVISIONS TO
EXCLUDE REPOSSESSION AGENCIES
AND PROTECT ITS EMPLOYEES WHILE
SEARCHING FOR COLLATERAL WHEN A
DEBTOR HAS FAILED REPAY THEIR
DEBT. LEGAL OWNER WHO HOLDS THE
NO COLLATERAL MAY ISSUE A
REPOSSESSION ORDER EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES THAT UNDER THE
REPOSSESSION ORDER A
REPOSSESSION AGENCY OR ITS
EMPLOYEE MAY COME TO THE
PROPERTY TO RECLAIM THE
PURCHASE. HAS FALLEN INTO DEBT
HOWEVER IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PROCESS DEBTORS WILL OFTEN
CALLED POLICE CLAIMING THE
REPOSSESS REDUCE TRESPASSING
ONTO THEIR PROPERTY. AS A
RESULT THE REFER THE THREE
EMPLOYEE GET THE RUN AS WE
RESTED REQUIRED TO GO TO COURT
FOR TRESPASSING ONLY FOR THE
CARDS THE CASE TO GET DISMISSED
AT THE HEARING. DUE TO THE
ARREST THE EMPLOYEE NOW HAS A
CRIMINAL HISTORY FOR SIMPLY
DOING THEIR JOBS EIGHTY FIVE
ONE FIVE WILL CLARIFY THE
PROFESSORS ARE NOT PUNISHED NOR
RESTER FOR TRESPASSING WHILE
SEARCHING FOR THE COLLATERAL
LASTLY THIS BILL WAS ON CONSENT
IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND HAS RECEIVED ZERO.
OPPOSITION THANK YOU IN A
RESERVE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN. C.
NOTICED DEBATE. THE CLERK WILL
OVER THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THAT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN OF A.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FIFTY ONE OF
FIFTY TO PASS TEMPORARILY. OUR
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR. THIS IS A C. R. FIFTY
FOUR. DEGREE ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA WINDS
DOWN TO EARTH MONTH MS
AGUIAR-CURRY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FOUR TO DESIGNATE THE
MONTH OF APRIL AS A CALIFORNIA
WINES DOWN TO EARTH MONTH THIS
YEAR MARKS THE TENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ANNUAL DOWN
TO EARTH MONTH CELEBRATION
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
SUSTAINABLE LEADERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA WINERIES AND GRAPE
GROWERS. AND WINE GRAPE GROWERS.
CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBAL LEADER
IN SUSTAINABLE WINEGROWING WITH
NEARLY 75% OF CALIFORNIA'S WINE
GRAPE ACREAGE AND 80% OF WINE
PRODUCTION. BEING SELF ASSESSED
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
SUSTAINABLE WINEGROWING. OTHER
STATE AND REGIONAL
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE LODI RULES. NAPA GREEN
SUSTAINABILITY IN PRACTICE
ALONG WITH SUSTAINABILITY
COMMITMENTS FROM WINE GROWING
REGIONS. THAT OUT OF THAT LIKE
MINE CINEMA COUNTY NAPA COUNTY
AND OTHERS ALL PLAYED A RLE IN
INSURING CALIFORNIA WINES ARE
PRODUCED IN AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
AND SOCIALLY EQUITABLE MANNER.
THE PURPOSE OF DOWN TO EARTH
MONTH IS TO ENGAGE CONSUMERS
POLICY LEADERS MEDIA AND THE
WINE TRADE THROUGH DIEGO
FRIENDLY EVENTS. SUCH AS EARTH
DAY FESTIVALS VINEYARD HIKES.
FOOD WINE FESTIVALS AND ECO
TOURS. I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THIS CHAMBER. TO
DRIVE OVER TO MY DISTRICT THIS
MONTH AND TAKE PART ON THE DOWN
TO EARTH MONTH EVENTS IN NAPA
VALLEY SO NOW MY COUNTY LAKE
COUNTY AD RIGHT DOWN THE ROAD
IN CLARKSBURG. WE ARE WORKING
HARD NOT ONLY TO PRODUCE THE
BEST TASTING WINES IN THE
WORLD. BUT ALSO THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY WINES
IN THE WORLD. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING I'M TRULY PROUD OF.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR FIVE VOTE AND THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN TO PARKING LOT
THERE'S- THANK YOU MS
AGUIAR-CURRY. C. MEADOW
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION
THE AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. OF AUTHORS. ON ACR
FIFTY FOUR THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
WELL CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED
IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS IT OPTED. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
TO TAKE UP. MR BERMAN'S ITEMS.
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT IS
AB. ELEVEN FORTY THREE. AND THE
CARBURETOR ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO CIVIL
PROCEDURE MR BERMAN YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES ARE RISING
PRESENT AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE
BECAUSE NO VICTIM OF HARASSMENT
SHOULD BE DENIED A PROTECTION
ORDER SIMPLY BECAUSE THE VICTIM
DOES NOT HAVE AN ADDRESS FOR
THE HARASSER. BUT IN THE CASE
OF CIVIL HARASSMENT EXISTING
LAW PROVIDES THAT PERPETRATORS
BE PERSONALLY SERVED WITH A
COPY OF THE PETITION FOR A
PROTECTIVE ORDER. TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER AND NOTICE OF
HEARINGWITHOUT EXCEPTION. THIS
DEFICIENCY IN THE LAW WAS
HIGHLIGHTED IN A RECENT
APPELLATE CASE. THE RESPONSE OF
AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE COURT TO ORDER
ALTERNATE MEANS OF SERVICE
CALCULATED TO GIVE THE
RESPONDENT NOTICE. THEREBY
REMOVING UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
FOR VICTIMS OF HARASSMENT TO
SEEK PROTECTION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MR BERMAN. SHE NOTICED QUESTION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. LOCAL OF
THE ROLL. CALL MEMBERS. USE
THAT AS WELL ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRED OF A. ALL MEMBERS HAVE
DESIGNED A VOTE. THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES AND NOW MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TEN. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AN ACT
RELATING THE PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS. IF MR BERMAN YOU MAY
GET OPEN IF YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TEN TEN A BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE ARCHITECTS
LICENSED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO COMPLETE FIVE
HOURS OF ZERO NET CARBON
CONTINUING EDUCATION PER TWO
YEAR LICENSE RENEWAL CYCLE WE
NEED TO ENSURE THE DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS ARE PREPARED FOR
A NEW KIND OF REALITY THE
CURRENT EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
IN CONTINUING EDUCATION
GENERALLY TREAT ZERO NET CARBON
DESIGN IS OPTIONAL I WOULD KNOW
THAT THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT TO
ME BY ARCHITECTS ASKING THAT WE
IMPOSE ADDITIONAL DUTIES. ON
THEIR PROFESSION THE COST OF
WHICH WILL BE BORNE BY THE
PROFESSION THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK BROUGH.
AVIS BERMAN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. A COUPLE
OF THE ROLE. YOU DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF. IS THAT ABOUT. WELL
CLOSE ROLE CHINA BUT I SEVENTY
ONE KNOWS ONE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS BACK IN REGULAR
FILE ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE AC ARE SIXTY ONE BY
MISS DAVIES THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES RELATIVE TO ORGAN AND
TISSUE DONATION. MISSTATED HIM
A OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I'M
HONORED TO PRESENT AC ARE SIXTY
ONE THIS MEASURE WOULD PROCLAIM
THE MONTH OF APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS DONATE LIFE DMV
PARTNERSHIP MONTH OF THE
CALIFORNIA. AND WOULD ENCOURAGE
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO REGISTER
WITH THE DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA
ORGAN AND TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY.
CURRENTLY MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
ARE WAITING FOR LIFESAVING
ORGAN. NOT EVEN THE LARGEST
FOOTBALL STADIUM IN THE U. S.
COULD FIT THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS ON THE NATIONAL
TRANSPLANT LIST. ARE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE POWER TO
HELP IF ONE PERSON DONATED
THEIR ORGANS EIGHT LIVES WOULD
BE SAVED IF ONE PERSON DONATED
THEIR TISSUE SEVENTY FIVE
PEOPLE'S LIVES WOULD BE HEALED.
THE ORGAN AND TISSUE DONOR
REGISTRY HAS PERSONALLY
IMPACTED ME AND MY FAMILY. IN
MY FAMILY WE HAVE PLACES TO
CANCER AND SO MY MOTHER
RECEIVED A KIDNEY TRANSPLANT
FROM NINETEEN YEAR OLD WOMAN
THAT LOST HER LIFE MY OTHER
BROTHER HAS IT AS WELL AND MY
OTHER BROTHER WAS ABLE TO
DONATE HIS KIDNEY TO HIM. IT
ALSO RUNS INTO THE DICK'S
FAMILY SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT FAMILY WILL BE DEALING
WITH FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIFE
AS AS CHILDREN COME IN SO. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MORE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
KEEP ALL CALIFORNIANS AWARE
INFORMED AT THIS REGISTRY TO
CONTINUE ORGAN AND TISSUE
DONATIONS THAT WILL HELP OTHERS
LIKE IT DID FOR MY MOM AND MY
BROTHER. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SHARE MY STORY AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF DECLARING APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS DONATE
LIFE DMV PARTNERSHIP MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO OPEN FOR FIRST WILL CALL FOR
A LOCAL AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS DAVIS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON THE
RESOLUTION. MISS DAVIS IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPENED FOR CO AUTHORS PURPLE OF
THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. BURKE WELL CLOSER ROLE
THERE ARE SEVENTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL BE TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS FIFTY SIX
AND.
FIFTY SEVEN. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO A VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WASHER MOVING ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND
ACTUALLY BE THE CHILD ABUSE.
WITH THAT THE CLERK ROLL OVER
THE ROLE. CALDERON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESERT ABOUT THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL. HIGHS SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. BURKE WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE FIVE
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO SUM MODEL
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT I SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO SYMBOL EIGHT FORTY
ONE I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN FORTY I
SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO ASSEMBLY GO
FIFTEEN SEVENTY NINE I SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL
FIFTEEN EIGHTY. FIVE SEVENTY
SIX NO ZERO AN ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. TWENTY
FOUR I SEVENTY SIX. NO ZERO.
MEMBERS I SEE A DOCTOR BILL. ON
THE FLOOR- DR HAS WELL A GIRL.
EMILY BECAUSE- AND SHE WILL BE
HIS DAUGHTER IN LAWS LAST NAME
THE ALL CAN GRAB THE PROUD
GRANDFATHER. DR COURT. YOUR
RECOGNIZE I RECOGNIZE SEVEN
POUNDS ELEVEN OUNCES AND FOR
ALL THE WOMEN HEAR ONLY A FOUR
HOUR LABOR SHE ARRIVED READY TO
GIVE BIRTH AT THE HOSPITAL'S
SPENT MINIMAL TIME A DID IT HER
WAY. IT WAS A- JUST ONE OF
THOSE MOST AMAZING THINGS THAT
EVER HAPPENS TO YOU THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE AN ITEM ON
CALL.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO
LIVE THE CALL. ON FILE ITEM
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE ALL THREE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO WISH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED UP IS FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS. TUESDAY
APRIL TWENTY OF CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY
FIRST CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY SECOND
THE FLOOR SESSION. IS AT NINE
AM ALL OF THE ITEMS REMAINING
WE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING OR FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MISTER 'DONNELL MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS. THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY
SECOND AT NINE AM. IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.